she's just some Instagram person that I
follow okay you don't know her IRL nope
nope no hey I'm Chloe I'm Danny and we
are a couple of idiots hello my name is
Nadia and I'm Brianna we've been
together for about three years now we've
been together about almost a year and
four months oh wow
time flies when you're having fun we
take a lot of pictures of our cats
because we haven't missed a game account
for her and she has a better phone I
don't know you're possibly I don't know
we're just not what kind of couple I
guess we do keep a lot of stuff quite
separate in our life all right thank you
that's Bob Dylan on the cover you see
alright didn't actually know you that
well so I'm gonna go through your photos
first cuz I love your photos they're
adorable okay there's a cat oh my gosh
she takes the best photos oh my god nice
picture that he took to try and surprise
me which I like what is this oh it was a
drawing that I did there's like ten of
these things on here this is like
literally whirring she's just some
Instagram person that I follow okay you
don't know her IRL no nope nope no I'm
curious about this girl actually all
right text messages oh I do think you
like her
I just have that sort of feeling about
it it's always one of the first people
to like our Instagram pictures this is
the thing that pops up first yeah you
recycle must like all must comment what
that is a twerking video I'm not sure
who that was
it definitely wasn't the person that
you're worried about anything juicy in
there she asked me about Valentine's
yeah that's why I'm looking at it but
you didn't say anything incriminating
like it was a terrible night and I hate
Chloe maybe it was romantic that's so
great and then he says also I'm around
today if you is because he fancies her
and they're gonna have to get an actual
answer if you like her or not actually
like we're friends we hang out I know
just look at your messages oh the
Facebook message is oh my gosh you no
one wants you to update I can't look at
her residence intentionally I've never
ever been on your Instagram I don't know
how you follow or anything
probably loss she's attractive
haha you talk down both texts and DM he
loves her obviously crack the case oh
she sent him three let me sing emojis is
that bad if I do that to a guy would you
like it oh no probably not
you guys oh I think she did a really
good job covering her tracks there or I
just have nothing to hide hmm I like
this story good you never close your
browser look at this how do you close it
been going on forever how do you close
it what do you think the crisps buns for
okay I've got Chloe Zacks phone first it
says hakuna matata on it
I love Lion King should I look at the
photos first interview so mostly us the
cat selfies of her more selfies of her
taking a lot of bathroom selfies there's
like one and when they look like nothing
I would send to anyone I don't want to
see old photos
then I'll show you there's me what kind
of fancy how she looks in the morning
that's what I like that was when I had
only one eyelash 'el and I sent it to my
friend looking at a lot of hashtags like
cake trishul oh yeah those for work I
make some cake drizzle satisfying
content whoo-hoo these posts mate you
sent the three hearts so now we're
starting to get somewhere earlier you
didn't like my platonic kissy face view
more three huh
artists this is a girl that is naked but
fully covered in glitter yeah it's a
painting and eating a bowl of glitters
all right I am going to now look at her
notes and the first one is break up with
current boyfriend how long can we use
our parents as an excuse for our
terrible behavior Big Bear cabin I like
yeah because I'm going to go to Big Bear
with people who never win me know on
your own with me doesn't agree we're
supposed to go and you just never said
anything about it it essentially is this
is entitled my story and it just says I
don't think there's any normal behavior
when it comes to cops fight or bit or
bite or sorry for adding without knowing
you I might have done it while I'm
checking your profile on my phone after
watching one of your videos
welcome my facebook anyways he's like
obviously trying to holler hold on I
just say that phrase in your life I'm
hip don't look at those messages I do
not consent
those are messages with my sister okay
he has taken the phone away
now she's deleting I'm not deleting and
that is I found out what I'm doing later
tonight it was pretty much what I
expected didn't see anything
particularly exciting I did think you
were talk too much as you talk to her
that's the one thing that's slightly
irritating but other than that like it
that's so minor in what could have been
on there I totally forgot about my
conversations with my sister and how I
wasn't actually comfortable with you see
in that you have the right to have like
private conversations with your sister
but it doesn't make me wonder what you
guys are talking about I'll show you
later where there's not cameras
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]